they are normally rivals but on Monday
all major news organizations in
Australia joined forces simultaneously
protesting restrictions on press freedom
by the government and in Parliament of
the opposition questioning the police
commissioners joined in Commissioner
have you seen the front page of the
Australian today it wasn't just the
Australian anything strike you is
similar in all of those from pages TV
adverts also highlighted concerns the
government can range analysts for
reporting the truth if it says you're
not allowed to know it couldn't happen
in Australia it's happening now
journalists are worried after police
raids in June on the home of one
journalist and offices of others who'd
run stories on the behavior of
Australian soldiers in Afghanistan their
work was based on documents leaked
illegally the police said by
whistleblowers media executives our
concern that there aren't enough
protections in the law to allow
journalists a public interest offence
when publishing information the
government wants to keep secret
if government operates on the basis of a
culture which is keep things secret
because we don't want it being discussed
then I think we as people we as
taxpayers we as effectively owners of
the government lose out media executives
say 75 different national security laws
passed since 2001 have chipped away at
the freedom of the press and need reform
that the government disagrees the
Australian people want to see balance in
the way we get on with the job but there
are national security considerations
that need to be taken into account
Reporters Without Borders says Australia
has dropped a twenty-first in its list
of countries with a Free Press
Monday's campaign highlights that not
many people buy physical
newspapers anymore but what these front
pages that represent is a much broader
conversation one that's happening in
Parliament on TV on social media and in
the streets about whether Australia's
government is becoming too or Thorat
Arian prioritizing it's right to hide
secrets over the public's right to know
Andrew Thomas al-jazeera
me